all right um good afternoon everyone um
i welcome you all to the african um omis
logic research inclusion with automatic
focus on bioinformatics education and
training um around the globe um i'm
convinced we've been having an enriched
and stimulated scientific discourse over
the
um course of the time these and
symposium has started
and at this point in time we are moving
on um to the african omics logic african
section
where um i'll have the privilege of
introducing us to the omics logic
um
okay great yes
we'll have opportunity of introducing um
omixlogic africa and um as part of that
i'll be talking about the programs we've
had here in africa uh in the past few
months as well as some of the
partnerships that is in the works for us
in advancing bioinformatics education
here in africa
uh moving on
uh i'd like to introduce myself
uh my name is adi kunia del hui i'm a
faculty with lead city um university
here in nigeria and i'm i'm an associate
of mls here and that's the medical
liberal science council of nigeria
importantly i'm a mentor and facilitator
with
mixed logic trainings of the prime
biotech um in corporation usa and i
double also as the
um director program director for mixed
logic again africa
so um the ole miss logic sets of
bioinformatics and big data analysis
training and programs of the prime
biotech
which has been globally proven by peer
reviews and then curriculum as part in
our partnering institution is being
inventively explored in closing the need
gaps that we have identified here in um
in with regards to bioinformatics
education and training um globally but
of of great importance for us is africa
and where we are you know located and
what we are doing in terms of these
scientific um i'm sorry in terms of
these is with respect to building
scientific capacities uh for researchers
for students for professionals you know
practicing on the on the feed and you
know across the continent our
postulation of course is um you know um
that increasingly by advancing the
knowledge of bioinformatics and its use
in obtaining scientific insight um you
know um
for from sequence data there will be a
significant growth and development of
the bioinformatics community um here in
africa and its considerable um
implications of course would be for
translational science uh you know from
understudy of the gene functions as well
as each rule in in biology and
agriculture and in medicine as well as
several other
you know peculiar um
space
so um
with this we are guided by lumis logic
and goals okay and um so we are pursuing
these with the goals set out by prime
biotech um for the omis logic programs
and this includes the um you know
provision of training in bioinformatics
that is geared towards enabling um
independent researchers um to to be able
to follow peer examples and you know get
guidance from mentors to carry out their
just their research we also seek to
develop a great community of
bioinformaticians with a shared passion
you know for data-driven research and
acquisition of citizen science likewise
our goal is to enable students
clinicians and faculty of our
backgrounds to develop novel and
independent research i'm using latest
technology um you know
in life and data sciences and so working
with these said google's home is logic
programs that we bring to our
participants across the african
community attempts to introduce
participants to big data and ngs
bioinformatics training which is
designed for everyone interested to
learn and apply data you know data
science key sets and computational
biology and skill sets to biological
data set and so they did the homilogy
programs post of everything a
participant actually needs to get
started and grow
in their bioinformatics and big data
analysis analysis space for for both
research as well as in their practice
so just as as we know that the
generation of biological data has
witnessed significant growth
in recent times
interpretation of this process data now
presents a huge challenge to to to to
everyone requiring of course most times
multi-steps multiple steps
bioinformatics tools human capacity that
are required to generate you know final
results from those i'm raw data and so
why the growing interest in
bioinformatics and big data analysis um
continues to grow here in africa many um
you know uh many of these kids are far
from being able to
i mean many of these scientists are far
from being able to utilize or gain
access to this key set for utilization
in their in their scientific research as
well as practice and so these girls are
are what we at omislogic africa we are
bridging with our training programs for
students faculties and researchers you
know across across the continent um
similarly um the lack of dynamism you
know when it comes to
continuous review of curriculum or as
well as updating of curriculum or for
our educational system by the
educational regulatory bodies also for
that means that many have been
disadvantaged in terms of learning this
essential bioinformatics knowledge and
skills in turn them with what is
obtainable in the global
you know scientific space and so our
approach at omislogic africa is
exploring um university partnerships so
as to integrate our hands-on
mentor-driven globally proven training
methods and resources into university
education both at undergraduate or
postgraduate training levels which um of
course we believe we have scaled rapidly
the growth and capacity of
bioinformatics you know within the
continent
and so um
in the course of the last 12 months we
have organized you know a number of
programs to bring bioinformatics
training with project guided learning
and resources you know to a
cross-section of participants um you
know they are ranges from beginners who
are totally new to bioinformatics as
well as students um and you know many
other faculties researchers i like um to
introduce them to bioinformatics and you
know
help develop their skill set and
research capacity in order for them to
be able to explore the world of ohmic
science and using bioinformatics and big
data analysis
knowledge and tools so this high impact
training you know includes of course
physical mislogic training we also
organize comics logic metagenomics and
training um in time past also we we
we have we have conducted the data
science for biology training and
likewise we we organized introduction to
bioinformatics bioinformatics and
computational biology bioinformatics for
biomedical drug discovery so these are
series of programs that we have you know
been able to um you know
package and bring to a cross-section of
participants in the past a month and
also similarly just as i mentioned
another time our our goal is to explore
partnership with you know notable
institutions universities here in africa
in order to be able to mainstream this
training this ominous logic training
into the um their curriculum for their
undergraduate and postgraduate students
as well as faculties alike so few of
such notable partnerships we've been
able to and forge towards achieving our
bioinformatics education and training
goals includes um deals with lead city
university here in nigeria we also have
crescent university also on our
partnership currently likewise we have
the motor research laboratory laboratory
and motor research laboratory of
oshawa state university here in nigeria
as well and lately we have a working
partnership with the university of
yandee in cameroon where we also brought
our omis logic training you know to the
um cross section of pakistan from these
institutions and i like to at this point
you know share some of this new table i
mean and sites from some of those
partnerships with us um you know which
ranges from the motor research
laboratory or for state as i mentioned
earlier on and include you know on to
you know redeemers college of technology
and management here in nigeria we
equally have madelike university um here
in nigeria lee city university as i
mentioned earlier on as well as um
crescent university where we have you
know interacted with experts and you
know management faculties to bring these
um you know trainings across um the
their students and um i'd like to you
know share at this point some of the
reviews not table reviews we've heard um
from our previous participants is
ordinarkins little beta who
who wants to those it's my first time
learning by informatics and i enjoy the
course a lot looking forward to more
opportunities to learn more but is a
medical laboratory scientist is a
practitioner who you know sees the needs
for him to you know gain these essential
skills equally we have undergraduates um
and he added to lewis swami is
representing this
um group of participants and she has to
say everything was new to me obviously
however it was easy to understand so
we're happy that we're able to carry
along the likes of adidas
in our training and equally we have this
coming in from samuel may capita who is
a postgraduate student from university
of lagos here in nigeria which was a
great opportunity to gain an experience
i'm glad to have i garnered some
information that the amount i paid for
the program isn't commensurate too it
was an eye-opening period i would be
glad to recommend by my friends
to equally experience so these are some
of the notable you know um reviews we've
gotten from our participants even as we
get um you know gear on in our efforts
to bring these trainings across more
participants within the african space so
um i'll conclude by i'm adding that
african continent has been regarded as a
crowd of modern humans uh and also the
african genomes has been reported to
contain more genetic variation than
those from many other you know other
continents and so this of course
presents a rich focus for scientific
scientific studies hence the need not to
um i mean to carry along the african
continent when it comes to genomic
research uh uh you know and discoveries
so um as we know bioinformatics has
become indispensable and indispensable
to you know for management of this
hugely generated data in modern biology
medicine and other related fields
however it is still um a is something to
grasp with um the fact that
infrastructure regards exist here in
africa and other challenges as well with
our educational system particularly with
the curriculum my integration of this
bioinformatics into into the into the
forwards of the universities all right